[Music]
and WTF news what are you talking about
submitted by BP champ all cool what's
the BP I don't know Mary oh well he's
the champion of all book lower high a
federal court has ruled in favor of a
young man who was forced to masturbate
in the presence of officers they had to
make sure that there were drugs in there
you got any drugs I'll push it out it's
mine that's my car sugar the book is
calm I'll never see you guys again I'll
be on the cop show sitcom dude you'll
see this all day and they'll be my
catchphrase yeah so this story is real
life Jaka yeah what else would it be oh
you'll get it out of there so I would
hopes for his sake it's like hey jerk
your dick but don't you come stop right
there yeah okay now stop oh yeah yeah
you're a good wife she knows officer
there's no way I would have killed him
why cuz I was that whole jacking off
like how like this so this all started
back in January of 2014 so there was
this 17 year olds that was sectioning
his 15 year old girlfriend so her mother
saw and reported the incidents of Police
Department why this girlfriend you can
be off woman legally fine
so eventually the detective that was
assigned to this case that name was
David Abbott I'm not I'm not gonna
continue then oh you're not paying
attention
it's like detective Abbott get in here
we got a job for ya [ __ ] and he's like
he's like what why why this kid said
it's X to his girlfriend fifteen year
old girlfriend I go get to the bottom of
it like that's what happened Abbott was
able to obtain a signed warrant to take
photographs of the teens naked body
including the suspects erect penis so
that he could compare it to the explicit
messages I know this actually got went
through it's [ __ ] creepy judge signed
off on exactly that's all you have to
confirm the penis you you just need
evidence there's no way around it I'm
trying to think of this no it was a
crime this is a verdict one to commit a
crime to solve the police station so man
he went over to her how a girl's house
to take a picture of her vagina no the
guy got the match his penis to the 16
penis I thought it was for some reason
it was her vagina and his penis that
they had to take pictures of call you
one
so Abbott was trying to take a picture
of the 17 year old
I'm detective Emmett is my partner
detective dingus we're gonna need to see
your penis son like you don't I mean
like that's what happened and he's like
it's not hard it doesn't look the same
hey start playing with it a little bit
do they get that guy with the big bulb
on the top to take the pot yeah right
yeah yeah this thing gets crazier so he
obtain that first weren't right they're
reporting that this was unsuccessfully
attempted so I don't know how far they
took it the penis didn't match or it did
man my interpretation it seems like the
kid just couldn't get
I'm glad that made the report the
suspect is unwilling to cooperate his
victim aim flaccid for the first 30
minutes yeah so then Abbot was able to
obtain a second warrant for authorizing
police to escort the team to a hospital
for an erection inducing injection oh
[ __ ] I don't get what's happening for
the story's sake what are those called
[Laughter]
he's hyperventilating over there this is
really sad but I'm so happy this is real
life why but I would like to know what
the injections are called for the
stories and purposes oh not for not for
not that ii warrant never like they
never took that photograph because of a
puppy because of public outcry thank god
will be tweeting this live like how did
the public get ahold of this information
before was it happen in 2014 so i'm
pretty sure in between investigation the
public yeah yeah how did it catch yeah
I'm not sure how they caught wind but I
just know that there was massive
whistleblower was in the department
there's pedophilia going on at the
Virginia police station yes so then
Abbott's committed suicide in December
of 2015
oh holy [ __ ] yeah a bit cuz he saw a
little boys dick when officers went to
arrest him on separate charges relating
to pedophilia
boom what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] judge
there maybe the judge is a pedo it's you
they don't convince them yeah they know
they're working against in judge
I need this hard dick for evidence yeah
and he's not willing to give it to me
well if you preface it with this is
gonna sound weird then it kind of
neutralizes what you're about to say and
I he probably did something like that I
thank you the judge is a pedo too and
they were in this together
and they was like I didn't want to share
pictures and then the judge is a little
bit harder and he just won't kill
himself like [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] you of
it what a sick piece of [ __ ] dude yeah
so when if police were gonna go arrest
him he said he's not going to jail he
pulled out a gun and shot oh because
they know what they what happens to
petals in a jail and former cops - yeah
so what kind of other petal things where
he was he getting charged yeah you know
oh yeah how did they would they find so
apparently he was he was having an
inappropriate relationship with the
thirteen-year-old boy for at least two
years what does that mean like texting
when them enjoy was 11 he was also a
youth hockey coach had a victim that was
in the hockey league man yeah so two
kids that we know of that was yeah yeah
so that happened with that and so now
the team that was subject to all that he
ended up suing Abbot's of states and so
now they're saying that yes it was wrong
that that should have never happened and
that's what we're talking about it now
judge yeah why is he still in business
at all
yeah judge horn you mentioned the judge
who signed off on that warrant on those
two warrants or maybe that maybe Abbott
worded it enough to where he's like left
out the age of the kid that's still such
a weak wit also does it say on the
warrant like we're gonna inspect the
dick like you know I'm saying like it
could be like they could have danced
around the lanes oh yeah oh yeah yeah we
used to get all necessary photos and
[ __ ]
so now you can suit you can sue in a
state so like the guy's dead right and
then the people that are benefiting from
the state I'm soon is his family and now
if you sue the state doesn't mean like
the family are the ones that lose out
the lawyers get a lot of money though
pretty great for them I mean the
funniest thing is like he could just go
to phone records and like I pee and [ __ ]
like that right he doesn't even have to
get his dick pic yeah so in the end of
that team he did end up serving one year
of probation oh hi
for that for him sexting and an underage
person but he's underage state law yes
she was fifteen but I'm in LA or
California standard that's fine because
her but what's the I don't know
Virginia's law uh so I guess he was
holdin yeah hmm it was just an excuse
for him to get more kitty dick pics why
is there so much peddle news happen in
these days just last night I saw two one
guy he was like a 22 year old that that
went to go meet up this kid but it was
like a FBI agent and and he had like
some pesto and some Sun Chips or
something I don't know why that was in
the article but it was weird and then
they were gonna [ __ ] he had like some
brand integration it was really about
the Sun Chips brand you know yeah but
you had like Vaseline oh my god he was
gonna booty do a 13 year old who's gonna
booty do it oh this is the 22 year old
guy yeah any any and he look like the
this old youtuber that did he look like
that dude the former Prime Minister of
Great Britain was a pedophile and they
the police and the government kept it
quiet for years and he ended up dying
and then information came up so he died
a happy dude being able to do whatever
the [ __ ] you wanted I do have a question
do you guys think that pedophilia would
one day be deemed natural no so for
example like you know back in the day
when homosexuality first came out people
were very against it right
they're like this [ __ ] is weird your
same-sex you're not supposed to be
[ __ ] and then later on the line
they started slow to accept it and
announced the norm it's okay that's two
adults consenting to it and like when
you're when it's kids in pedophilia like
they don't know what they know
yes yes it's two adults but that's not
the point I'm making the point I'm
making is at one point in time people
were looking against it and then now
we're looking at it against another who
knows maybe in 2050 2050 pedophilia is
widely accepted and there's people that
are like yeah we should have pedophilia
marriages there are groups like that out
right now oh there are oh yeah there's a
couple of them and there's like it's
NAMBLA North American man-boy love oh
they're there I mean it was widely
accepted in in Greece and Rome because
we could all be wrong right now before
the study of like what it does to the
[ __ ] brain the same the same argument
in nature like well homosexually occurs
like amongst feline like they [ __ ] each
other there's [ __ ] homosexual flowers
there's also a ton of pedophilia in
nature and animals too I've never seen
its natural gia its natural deal just
open your brain open your brain I've
never seen puppies getting [ __ ]
[ __ ] by they hump each other
same-sex thoughts help each other all
the time I'm talking about the
pedophilia part of it
that happens they always take like all
that a young dying the [ __ ] of breeding
all the time I don't think you guys
understand his question is basically do
you think it'll ever happen when
everyone's worth were there's wide adopt
lady just man married or chandelier the
other day so yeah I understand but I'm
just saying I say my argument that are
used for homosexuality can be used for
pedophilia
that's what I'm saying I think the main
thing is consent like because gay adults
whatever they can consent when it comes
to a little child people know that their
brains aren't developed enough to
actually fully understand yeah on so
that's the main argument that's why
varies by state and country but I think
all over the world [ __ ] a
three-year-old is wrong yeah I mean yeah
I mean gay gay people would tell you
that I mean
it's it's not the same like one is like
like I would say a defect in like your
genetics or whatever like you you're
attracted to like yeah kids and
doorknobs and [ __ ] exhaust pipes of a
car and one is just assume that it's
like a lot like guys or girls or yeah
like when you're when you're developing
you just have feelings that way yeah so
yeah and what is the what's the
difference between those two things like
why do i why am I born like liking women
like compared to like somebody who is
born liking pedophilia I don't know but
we should kill those people
thank you they will burn in my kingdom
well what if what if it's a pedophile
that's never acted upon it he's living
with it endured they never committed the
crime they don't do the time like if you
okay so it's like I want to steal a
million dollars but I never acted on it
yes say Steve was like I [ __ ] load
three rolls I want to [ __ ]
three-year-olds so bad
no but he's never done it well you still
be like okay with him yeah never done
he's never done he's never like bought
any child porn he's a rebel like I mean
there's I think all of us are like that
right like we want like I wanna murder
people yeah we have we fantasize about
all kinds of crazy thing if you like
wanted to [ __ ] like you know I don't
know if like a 30 year old dude you know
who's like cool limbs like a pretty cool
guy you know I wouldn't like I wouldn't
judge you for that hey thank you
[Music]
[Music]